I was letting I was intentionally going
over eleven because I know some people
were checking out but it looks like most
everybody's back right okay great
so Sean suggested I think it's a great
idea that we go around the table and and
have the right deep let's on introduce
yourself negate yourself completely that
we each take an opportunity either to
reflect on the conference or what we
want to see if we were ever to do this
again I would love to hear that if
anything shifted for you however I'm
giving you each five minutes is that too
much even you think it's too much yeah I
think it's gonna take five minutes on
the outside you're allowed to take one
minute but at five minutes I really need
a heavier object I'm gonna start using
my computer Oh genius okay I'll start
tapping the glass okay so she wanna just
start with Massimo and go around
I got you started click so first of all
this was a great experience and and
thanks a ton for for bringing about and
to you to bring you about as well and I
was a little skeptical honestly one the
first time that that's how you
approached me saying you first of all
you're not gonna convince this many
people to come into the same place in
the same time you did
and second of all I'm sure there's gonna
be a you know interesting fistfight or
but nothing more nothing more than that
turns out I ain't seen much in the way
of fistfights I'm not sure that people
necessarily have changed their mind I
know I have not significantly moved from
my initial positions but on the other
hand I wasn't expecting that I think
that's unreasonable I mean most people
most thoughtful people change their mind
after a while that they carted it on
things you know this is one more
experience that puts input into my brain
both conscious and unconscious and and
eventually I'll you know I keep thinking
about area keep being exposed to
different views of the different ways of
presenting this I'm used by different
people and sometimes you do change your
mind
about things I certainly have learned a
lot about people's positions I have
identified two or three areas where I
think actually I'm stronger in my
position than I was before and I have
identified one or two areas what I need
to be concerned and think about it so
and the other thing I think that we
shouldn't really underestimate even
though it does sound sort of
touchy-feely it was nice to actually see
people in person and have a beer with
Jerry last night and you know just chat
with Alex at the same time the same
table and that sort of stuff just to
mention two of my usual antagonists okay
I guess it's one way to put it because
that way you know you put a human face
on things and the next time you you
attack the ideas but you're more careful
about liking the person which I think
it's something that I personally strive
for but sometimes I fail so in terms of
that sort of general ideas it seems to
me clear that I need to be more about
more in the in the philosophy of physics
the primarily physical literature in
physics particular in quantum mechanics
it's a little difficult so I might
actually ask people for suggestions for
you know second level sources but I find
that that area actually very interesting
as far as of course it's relevant to
almost everything we've discussed today
because it goes at the roots of what
does it mean to be a naturalist to be a
determinist and to be a reductionist
and those are clearly philosophical
questions that are informed not much by
biology as much as by fundamental
physics so that's what I need to
concentrate more more efforts at the
same time I think I think that that
I've been made to think about things
like like the freewill debate I think
I'm now convinced that we really need to
stay away from that term
I mean I've actually you know this is an
agreement who Jerry yes it was well it
was a partial shift I mean I've actually
thought about that before but but this
this time is definitely put me over the
edges and you know I really really
should try to avoid that that thing
because it's just not helped not the
topic obviously that the terms because
it's really not not helpful and I guess
however in terms of sort of substance I
confirm myself closer to a guest dance
position or some variation there thereof
in terms of what I actually think about
that I still yes that's okay I don't
have a lot else to say at the moment the
other thing that I'm concerned about
about is that this whole thing of about
emergence I think that we have not
explored in now non-mystical numb miss
durian interesting ways in which you can
talk about emergence which I think are
there out there there's at least couple
different ways for instance the word
supervenience has never come up which is
kind of interesting supervenient is what
after if in there is at shipping I
actually I also don't think it's
particularly useful in disgusting
emergence because it actually deals with
a very weak version of emergence but it
should have come up at least even even
just as as to dismiss it I mean there
are interesting areas they are in the
philosophy of physics where where we
could go back and revisit that topic and
yes I will come back to something like
this perhaps more focused on a subset of
of topics obviously um I was skeptical
about this whole conference to be honest
I did not like to general idea I
basically anything Shawn wants to do
turns out to be interesting and I'm
interest but this one was to me way too
philosophical in its concept I thought
and I was ready to be surprised if
anything would really come
out of it other than a lot of very
gentle talk where I'm ending up is still
with my reverence to science but feeling
that feeling that there are topics which
I was concerned about with science
because we weren't getting answers and
I've come to the conclusion that there
is a point where philosophy is basically
subducting under science where it's it's
convenient to throw those topics the
philosophy whether it's many worlds or
anthropic or what which at least on a
temporary basis philosophy could look at
work at and maybe ultimately throw
useful ideas back to science which will
help turn those in back into scientific
principals and vice versa so to this
cool I'm getting more reverence for
philosophy than I had before although I
don't want to spend a lot of time
reading it so for Dan's books which I do
read but I will say I mentioned this to
Sean
this has fundamentally changed my life
as it turns out because one of the
subjects that I was very interested in
because it feeds into my background and
what I've been working on which is the
criminal justice system and it has
really changed my mind because even
though I think it's possible I might be
among the most hardcore naturalist here
and I don't know if there's free will I
don't know if there's consciousness and
to me at least we prove it to me
nonetheless it's clear that we got to
work with these concepts in society and
act as if they exist otherwise it's
going to be very complicated for society
I don't think we should be patronizing
and hold back our reverence for
naturalism at the same time I think we
could work with concepts of volition and
we need to in terms of our justice
system in the way society works I think
we need to radically overhaul the
criminal justice system and I've been
thinking that I am even more determined
than ever to work on that I'm not sure
there's a big difference between how we
should treat people who are criminally
insane and people who are criminally
guilty because I think that there are
concerns about free will and about
volition and and I
already been thinking that but it is
really confirming my dedication to do
that I think that we've got an evil
justice system that needs to take into
account a modern neuroscience another
concepts we talked about here so thank
you all for helping me come around to
that and my other thought which I
mentioned the beginning that I could
change my mind about the value of
bringing a lot of smart people together
and a lot of cool things come from that
haven't changed my mind
it really can happen so it's been a
really great meeting all of you and up
there a pleasure to have been able to
facilitate it and thank you for your
patience with my in my naivete Simon um
so I I had I had three things I thought
I would just bring up and they're short
and I promise so so I had obviously you
know being in the same room with
intellectual heroes is great I feel like
I'm 12 because I first read many many
people here when I was twelve that's
right you're always the youngest person
in the room were the oldest so that's
true so the thing I learned a huge
amount about was reductionism
explanation inner theoretic
relationships the first day was just
huge for me I understood Sean much
better this notion of entailment these
are some really provocative concepts
that I'm gonna take back and wrestle
with and thank you for for indulging me
when I tried to put something up on the
board and so I'm really grateful
one thing I was surprised we didn't get
into as much was functionalism so you
know evolution is a huge pillar of
modern science and I think functionalism
is too I should I've been told I should
explain better so I was talking to david
poeppel last night about his work and
his work is about the computational
states of the brain at least as I
interpret it the way that we talk about
the way David talks about it seems to be
in some ways the domain of computer
science particular theoretical computer
science and which is how I how I think
about social systems and yet there seem
to be a huge number of problems that
emerge there that are both conceptually
interesting and also perhaps provocative
for notion
of responsibility moral responsibility
and so let me just bring up one right so
we like to attach moral value to the
conscious part of ourselves if I'm
sleepwalking and I kill somebody maybe I
shouldn't be held responsible for it
even if the best rational engagements of
my brain are making me do it
and I there's something we slid past a
little bit here which was what if the
conscious part of our brain is not the
most rational part should that part to
that part we don't feel the given value
related to that are we think better in
groups so should conversations be these
citizens should they have rights should
if Dan and Rebecca are having a great
conversation and their mental states are
interacting with each other in producing
a larger scale computation first of all
does it feel anything
second of all should we you know confine
them so that this conversation doesn't
stop or maybe conversations like to die
there like banthas or the meal that the
end of the universe that the restaurant
of the interview is the one who wants to
be eaten so and I think the third thing
I hope I'm not have how much time do I
have dad though two minutes two minutes
great so I'll be very quickly so biology
and neuroscience to me seem like very
mature subjects actually and it's one of
the reasons perhaps they don't work in
them because it seems like many of the
research programs are very clear and the
many of the things you want to do it's
like let's get some dishes and do the
right things and I've been disabused of
that by the exchanges in this corner of
the room here but one thing I would love
to see more discussion of is the some of
the questions that come up in economics
or social sciences and so Dom brought
some of these up so I've always had this
feeling that game theory was secretly
about rationality okay good okay so
people say the rational thing to do is
defect and that's why Nash equilibria or
these kinds of things I'm like what's
going on there and I would love to see a
little more excavation as to what
economics and the social sciences say
about thinking what it means to think
what the nature of rationality is I
think you brought this up a little bit
and I and I missed it I have you know
just parenthetically and you'll be
lovely to excavate that more if we came
back it's just to go to the sciences
that are really fuzzy and dirty and
we're sort of the questions maybe are
just simpler and more obvious to play
with so anyway I'm of course very
grateful and you've been very kind to
the to answer my questions I'm very
grateful thank you I've been quiet
during this morning in part just to sort
of catch what's going on I have never
considered myself clearly in any field
and that I think is both a problem and
an advantage it's also that the bad
story about you know maybe you're just a
dilettante as a result and so you know
I've done my best to do do good work in
each of these areas and look deeply into
it but but always in that and the
problem is the interesting questions are
always between fields and you can never
do enough you can never get it all and I
think that's one of the real challenges
we we've experienced in having a group
of diverse people talk about things
actually helps you figure this out I
mean I had never heard of this this guy
you just mentioned and yet I've taught
most of my career levels of selection
stories spent them you know as having
studied with Lew Anton with Gould with
with Wilson and even you know even
Hamilton for a year I had all this stuff
in my head it was all going on and we've
been arguing about it all along and yet
to find out that there's somebody that
somebody at least thinks is terrific
that I didn't know about is a real
surprise to me so I think that's one of
the real advantages of this I should say
that as I mentioned before I I sort of
have wandered back and forth between
these fields never being in any one real
field and I've mostly just followed
questions all of my career and the
questions lead you elsewhere they'll eat
you out of your field often times and
yeah it's easy to get in trouble when
you do that and yet I think it's the
most exciting and the most for me I feel
like it's almost a noble quest to sort
of put yourself out there and get kicked
around a little bit because you learn in
the end you
figure out where you're wrong and you
can make new turns I think that's great
I also mentioned that you know one of
the people that really influenced me
very very indirectly was a physicist
that you know I thought I started in
physics I didn't want to go there but
earlier when Schrodinger's book what his
life I think really changed the field of
biology across a discipline even though
he was not talking about things that
were really in that discipline and I
think you know those of us in
evolutionary biology actually haven't
learned some of the lessons that he
talked about there he or at least the
hints he provided and one is I was
hoping you are this this this conference
interestingly enough was especially a
debate with Dan and with with with
Richard about evolution because I've
come to change my thinking about
evolution and of course with with Jerry
because of the Schrodinger argument
about the the problem of entropy
production and it's really changed my
thinking about biology and it's changed
my thinking about the way evolutionary
biology works I think one of the
interesting things about evolution Dan
made the point that the Darwin has
contributed a lot in women anyways to to
the philosophy philosophical world but
in many ways this is a really serious
question about what kind of causality is
it how do we think about that nature of
causality and how do we link it with
other kinds of physical causality and I
think it's very close to one of the
reasons that I've sort of shifted recent
discussions towards very very simple
questions about the origins of life is
because I think we we still don't have a
clue what we're talking about and
interestingly enough I think it's
relevant to questions about mind and how
the brain works
and the fact is that I don't think we're
going to get at those questions until we
become this we're willing to follow the
interdisciplinary route work between not
just the scientists but between the
science and philosophy as well and even
though there's a lot of disconnect and I
still feel there's a lot of disconnect
and we certainly found it here I'm gonna
just make a little side comment about
the criminal justice system which I love
your comments about this my wife worked
for ten years running a what's called
the prison for special offenders these
are people who are mentally ill and
wordy
so dangerous they couldn't be put in the
hospital really really extreme
personalities just trying to get into
their minds trying to figure out what
goes on is such a mind opening
experience you know it's it's it's it's
almost psychedelic you might say that
you know they're so different their
minds are so different really I think
this is also part of the neurosciences
that we don't we don't really have a
sense of how big that difference is and
there's this whole thing called
personality disorders we don't really
have good neuroscience for it we're sort
of getting at it but it's because we
don't really have a very good general
theory about how brains work and one of
one of my problems is that every time I
begin to study one of these questions I
say okay this is what David does to us
know what can I do physically to answer
the question so I interested early on
about human beings and language I
realized that doing the language stuff
was going to be really hard but maybe I
could look at brains what's different
about a human brain and chimpanzee
brains and a monkey brain maybe that
would tell me something about it leads
me to other questions that my time
already
oh ouch okay well let me just we just
end with one piece and that is that this
has been great I can't say that my mind
has been changed but I'm worried about
how general naturalism is and my view of
the problem is that naturalism was
implicitly a negative statement what
we're not these other guys and we
quickly said when I can talk about those
other guys but that makes naturalism
almost negatively defined and I was
worried about that as a starting point
and this is why I think muscle and
Massimo says maybe we should be talking
more specific things for conferences
that sort of focus in on specific things
might have actually been a little more
helpful but it's a good stock crisscross
time too at the end so that'll be good
to respond to Terry
okay so um I came to this meeting us
thinking that I was a beleaguered
minority representing mad dog
physicalism and I'm very relieved to
discover that so far from being a mad
dog so far from being a beleaguered
minority well my differences with others
especially people of whose views I have
long respected are matters of emphasis
and shading um that's very reassuring to
me um it's also extremely important and
valuable but for a group like this to
get together in the complete absence of
non-naturalistic we can let our hair
down and express what we really believe
without worrying about its ramifications
for broader debates um that's why I
regret that this is videotaped and being
put on YouTube oh there's only one issue
that I regret we did not discuss at
greater length so that I could get a
clearer handle on it um we had a
persistent disagreement around the table
about emergence and some of us insist
that there is there is emergence and it
is not a problem for naturalism and of
course adjudicating this claim requires
us to pin down a concept of emergence
and adult think it's going to require us
to pin down a concept of naturalism
because I think there we are all pretty
much in the same region of conceptual
space and of course it's too late to do
that now but that is
so I have off to --safe 5 I think very
brief things each under a minute and I
see my time - yeah I won't take them so
sir five five things connected so first
I remain this makes me feel positive and
optimistic about the positive program of
naturalism I'm very confident about its
legs to carry on among intellectuals and
in a pot as a positive program and what
I mean by the positive program I mean at
least as committed to more than just the
denial of supernaturalism in the realm
of knowledge growth in production but
actually as a program but that basically
is is comfortable with the idea that
what there is and all there is is
natural and that and and in some ways
maybe not in a self-centered way but the
idea that maybe we're smart enough to
keep figuring out the secrets of nature
second thing though I'm still nervous
I'm as nervous as I was before I came in
about the prospects for naturalism in
the wider culture I just think that it's
nice to be in a place like this among
like-minded people but I still think the
that whether or not the wider culture
will come around is a completely open
question and I get nervous about it
but number three I think a key that came
out at this conference to whether or not
the prospects for naturalism are on the
positive side or negative side depends
upon whether we can find secular
communities for secular meaning
mosques of mattering something like that
to be ecumenical so that we're not
Bowling Alone I mean and I think we I
think what Canton to came out nicely is
that we take this problem you know
seriously some more than others the
fourth thing is and this this relates to
something Alex said maybe I'm
accentuating the positive this is my
nature the the half-full aspect I was
happy but maybe was under discussed I
was happy that the kind of naturalism
that I thought was discussed here was
not reductive and was not a limit abyss
and was happy with naturalistic
emergence I guess I would put it that
way coming in we're comfortable with
talking about levels and emergent
phenomena but I I think that what alex
is way of putting it it was under
discussed so we're not I'm not positive
you know yeah and and finally this goes
back to something Massimo said my view
was strongly confirmed that although
almost everything I think Dan says about
if you were going to give a positive
view of freewill
this is what it should look like it
should be a compatible inception I think
that what Jerry and then the discussion
that he helped us have shows that the
concept of free will is so contested so
embedded in several different traditions
that it would be better if we just said
we're not going to talk about that
anymore I mean I took this position in
writing in 2000 and the problem of the
soul I just said it is a philosophical
black hole that sucks in all smart
people and then we don't come out and
there's no light chatter so I do think
that that switching up the conversation
saying that has too many connotations
there's these contested meanings we'll
go back to what Aristotle said let's
talk about voluntary and involuntary
let's talk about when John Dewey says I
gave this quote today and I think many
many years ago from Dewey Jay he says
what men and women have fought for in
the name of freedom has never been
metaphysical freedom of the will it's
always been political freedom social
freedom
and then secondly I think on the
freewill topic the Devils in the details
and I very much agree with what Terry is
said following up on the comment about
criminal justice which is so helpful you
know we're gonna figure this out it's we
can't be this is part of the
naturalistic program I mean we're here
now it's a long long program it'll take
for as long as we're around we'll figure
out the different causes of human
behavior and then we're gonna have to
make wise judgments about which causes
we think are exculpatory and which ones
are not and and we are going to have to
take into account what Simon said too is
we may over rate the and ascribe moral
worth or lack of worth to events to much
based on the more the more the conscious
proximate causes and it just may be that
as we understand the whole system better
we'll have a better view about human
action and that will change I think our
conception about moral morality in the
law but that's a long way down the road
I have nothing enlightening to say
except wait and see thank you I see my
four seconds and for that I'm docking
him for seconds so right so thanks
everyone for this most interesting few
days I enjoyed it a great deal so no I
don't think my mind has been changed but
a few important things I think were
reinforced and clarified to some extent
so ah right I've I found yesterday
afternoon's discussion the paint
although I realized it must have been
for non philosophers I did find it quite
helpful in getting clearer as to what's
at stake in some issues I've thought for
a very long time
that the real challenge to the only
challenge to naturalism I take truly
think should be taken truly seriously is
a kind of illuminant of his challenge
roughly the kinds of Alex defense that
is you know our James in my book is
subtitled metaphysics naturalized
naturalizing metaphysics I forget which
metaphysics naturalized right well of
course the alternative is to is the only
alternative we really take seriously to
naturalizing metaphysics is abolishing
metaphysics right it's self-evident to
me that non naturalized metaphysics is
nonsense so and I think if we were
persuaded by Alex that is the road to
about that that's abolition of
metaphysics now I also have always
thought as well and this was reinforced
yesterday that that issue ultimately
comes down to the question of whether we
can successfully ground notions of
representation because once you get
representation we can get all the rest
of the stuff that's really at issue can
we grab notions of representation
seriously not just in a metaphorical
fashion but actually technically
grounded in information and resistance
to entropy so I happily came out of
yesterday's conversation thinking right
there's a kind of general agreement that
that is that's the project that has to
be carried out and ultimately I think
that's what determines whether we could
have whether we shall have naturalized
metaphysics or no matter physics I'm
going to join the general consensus that
we've heard around the table and I was
also persuaded that y'all free will just
looks like it's got to as a phrase looks
like it has too many barnacles on it and
this of course happens sometimes too to
phrase I mean rationality is not do is
it is another one like that in my in the
first chapter of the book I'm currently
if anything up on economics I say on
philosophy of economics I say you know
rationality rationality has typically if
InterVarsity ever meant anything
rationality has meant what God would
think right since there's no God I'm not
going to talk about rationality again in
this book I mean I think it used it once
was a really good word but it's been
ruined right so so it's time to retire
it I'm inclined to think that about free
will and I'm not you know again my
sympathies on the sub
substantive issues are entirely with
dance view I'm a compatibilist in that
sense but I think we should we should we
will we will probably never succeed in
in persuading people to understand that
compatible this position if we insist on
using the phrase pretty well so ok let's
retire I I would have enjoyed a little
more description in terms of things we
cook that I would have liked or Cena's
talk a little bit more about I would
have enjoyed more discussion about
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
it would have been nice if that was
actually a topic
it came up parenthetically now and again
but we really didn't didn't have a go at
it
I James and I have written I've recently
written a paper which is coming out in
the book we're editing from Oxford you
pee in a cup next month in which we
defend the original Copenhagen
interpretation not the later Copenhagen
interpretation right not the köppen
there so all right the Copenhagen
interpretation that only the Copenhagen
interpretation that according to
philosophers isn't an interpretation
Yeah right in that one ok original
original original board so we could have
had an interesting go about that yeah
well it was okay all right I'll stop
there thanks thanks everybody for so
many interesting remarks at every one
all right so yeah for me also the the
movement of the workshop was not in the
direction changing my mind about things
but certainly in the direction of
sharpening ideas I had about things very
much in a very important way one of the
pre-existing ideas I had coming in was
that it's always fun to bring smart
interesting people into the same room
and good things happen that you don't
predict and that was absolutely verified
so thanks everyone for participating in
that um I guess the other the major idea
about naturalism in sort of the idea I
have belt naturalism moving forward ba
naturalism itself rather than all the
Disciplinary interests is the idea that
there is one world the natural world but
there are many ways of talking about
that natural world and it's
understanding the many ways of talking
about and how they fit together
they're useful or rejected that is the
important part of the program so I can't
resist mentioning one of the papers that
was foundational for my understanding of
thinking about layers and Merchants and
things like that was by Sidney Coleman
who taught Janna and me quantum field
theory many years ago in 1975 he wrote a
paper called quantum sign Gordon
equation as the massive Turing model
anyone else had this as their favorite
paper so it's about he found he finds a
model theory in one dimension of space
one dimension of time and it's actually
two theories there's a theory called the
quantum sign Gordon equation which is
just a terrible terrible term that he
used as a joke and then caught on we
have a boson since we're going back to
bosons and fermions there's a boson in a
particular potential and the potential
is just a sine wave it goes up and again
and there's a whole nother theory which
is a theory of fermions also in one
spatial dimension where these fermions
can bump into each other and interact
and what Coleman shows in and that
utterly independently written series one
Theory bosons one Theory fermions and
Coleman proves mathematically that
they're secretly the same exact theory
that in this boson Theory not only have
little oscillations in the potential
which looked like bosons but you also
have big variations which go from one
minimum to another and they act like
fermions
and you crank up the coupling constant
and you show that every thing that you
can calculate in one theory is exactly
the same as you would get from doing it
in the other theory so here is one
reality with two very very different
ontology that are equivalent in every
possible way so that liberated my
thinking about the right way to think
about reality in that it made me think
that different ways of talking about the
same underlying reality are just as good
and I would say that's even true if
they're not equivalent if like
thermodynamics is a subset of the domain
of applicability of the atomic theory
that underlies it but nevertheless my
own personal view be that the concepts
of thermodynamics are equally real and
be part of how to talk about things and
so I would say the same thing about
whatever it is we call volition or
freewill I'm kind of getting sympathetic
to the idea that free will has too many
barnacles that I think that an
interesting idea but nevertheless so
even if you buy all that of the ways
that we have of talking about the
natural world there are two different
species there are the sort of
descriptive vocabularies and there are
the normative vocabularies and I think
they're both important but I think that
the ways that we have of talking about
them and validating them are very
different and that's something we didn't
quite get into talking about it at a
very specific level but I think that
both the parallelism is important and
the differences are important I think
that when we decide what is moral what
is right or what is aesthetically
beautiful or what is artistic these are
all vocabularies for talking about the
world but in those normative spheres we
don't have recourse to the simple and
and consensus scientific apparatus that
we have for the descriptive points so we
have contention and I think that Act I
was surprised that there seemed to be so
much potential common ground when we
were talking about morality that we all
have impulses in us and we're all gonna
have to use some communicative process
to work out how to develop that into a
theory of morality so one conclusion of
the workshop for me is that I'm even
more optimistic about naturalism than I
was before and I would even say that not
only academically but also publicly I
think that you know I see a way forward
to making this a compelling story to
tell people I don't think that we have
the vocabulary in the rhetoric to do it
yet I don't think we have the social
aspects that we all agree are important
but I see no obstacles in the way to do
that and you know 100 years from now and
that's when everyone is a naturalist
they will look back and go yes there was
that moment in Stockbridge when it all
got off the ground exactly and I'm done
perfect
everybody for the all you've taught me
and what I've learned in particular is
how difficult some of these issues are
and how in spite of having a bunch of
really smart and well-intentioned people
around the room there's still tremendous
possibilities for miscommunication where
you can do these hidden pitfalls where
you can fall in a hole and you don't
realize so you're halfway through the
talking you realize somebody's jumping
up and down and what's that about and
then so you echoing what Shawn just said
or not echoing it but recasting it I
think Shawn was acknowledging the
distinction between the manifest and the
scientific image and the difficult task
of putting them into registration and
what we've heard is that there are
several terms the don't go nicely at all
one of them is designed we had an
interesting debate of that one of them
is freewill itself one of them is
emergence and another one is rationality
well there's four Biggie's right there
and I'm gonna add a fifth one which is
imaginary because it's an old thought
experiment mine which I think clarifies
this we we go to some distant
archipelago and we find people that
speak English except for one thing where
we talk about being tired bushed
exhausted they talk about all the
fatigues they have oh I got so many
fatigues in my body now more fatigues in
my legs and in my arms and that's just
that that's their conceptual scheme
that's why they talk and we show up and
they say all right mr. mr. scientist
mrs. scientist tell us what fatigues are
now what do we do do we say there aren't
any fatigues and they say there are any
fatigues run around the block you'll
know fatigues I can feel them so that's
not a very profitable pursuit if we say
well I'll tell you what fatigues are and
then we take on the bizarre task of
trying to come up with a identification
of fatigues with very insufficient
necessary sufficient
we've got a lot of things about blood
sugar and lactic acid well that's
something no what we want to do we say
look turns out your term doesn't carve
nature at the joints really we'll teach
you this other stuff instead and we'll
just sort of show you how you can go
back and forth between them and we're
gonna define fatigues and we're not
going to eliminate fatigues you want to
go talk about fatigues
the way we talk about sunsets fly now I
think that the moral of that story
applies for all of these terms so what
do I think what let's take the one that
matters to me the most here first of all
I would say emergence for me I just
assume get rid of the term because I
think that there's so much baloney
that's been said about emergence it's
it's it's got more than barnacles on it
I don't mind barnacles all that much
there's other stuff I don't want terms
free will is in a very delicate position
because if you've just banished it you
create a vacuum of social vacuum which
is really scary you've got all these
people out there saying soil shows we
don't have free will and therefore
nobody is ever responsible and and
therefore well nobody nobody nobody is
thinking through the implications of
that if you've got that well one person
has thought through the implications and
that's Bruce Waller in the book that
I've sent you all a review of and you
read that you think whether you really
like the direction that that's going so
when I said that these issues are
political part of the political problem
I think is that we do have to talk to
the to the non-scientific
non-naturalistic world about these
things and terms that we can agree on
how best to use may nevertheless
backfire in our face was very badly and
I just want to say one more thing about
that sort of political issue I have come
to the view actually just this morning
that before this goes out on the web it
really should be test flown very
cautiously and carefully with some non
naturalist audiences not don't send it
to them because then it's out but
somehow get them to sit down and see the
edited version because I look back on
these few days and I think we are
letting ourselves open for incredible
misuse of our words and that the candor
that we have in Dalton this weekend
could come back to haunt us as various
people deliberately misinterpret what we
say and that we could really regret them
you know I mean I mean creationist
religious types that that it would be
possible it would be yes there's also
that yet I mean we've also then go
we've also bad-mouthed a whole lot of
people not very often they mean them so
I said but I think that that we really
should take very seriously that we
cannot count on the goodwill of the
people that are going to have this and
and they will we encounter on their
ill-will and this is the one problem
okay dancer I think we this will
definitely come up in the crosstalk and
you know of course philosophers are
famously more cautious about their
language than physicists we're just sort
of like take it or leave it man but but
it's a good point and then
we want to go to david fascinating
weekend it was very helpful for me for
therapeutic reasons actually because i
had a very difficult couple of weeks and
being here and listening to this was
after you took my mind off of other very
serious matters in my life i appreciate
i was entertaining the a changed my mind
about two things I changed my mind about
freewill and morality and and those are
big ones because I because I'm so naive
I thought that's as scientists and could
actually tackle at least part of it
because we don't think of those as
undecomposed holes all our discussions
about freewill and morality as as if
those were monolithic concepts but when
we try those out in that kind of you
know as scientists we break we break an
act of free will or moral judgment down
into its constituent parts and my
presupposition has always been those you
can't study so that's different that we
had this discussion briefly yesterday as
yeah it's different than talking about
the normative standard for morality but
it or the actual act of making a moral
judgment that I think I don't see why
you can't study that I think you can
that being said I changed my mind about
that I think we shouldn't because I
think that the even if we're very
pedantic and careful about decomposing
these concepts into their constituent
parts we're not ready and we it looks
like we're gonna need some philosophy to
do a better job parsing these into into
parts that we can actually investigate
so I'm changing my mind about both of
those I thought I wasn't sympathetic to
any of the for instance neurobiological
analysis of these I think they're shitty
and you know but that doesn't mean
people aren't doing serious work is but
I say it so I changed my mind that for
that for me should be off the table for
now okay game theory
yeah I'm not nothing I'm sympathetic to
it as a formalism the my regret is that
and we didn't talk about something very
nuts and bolts about education I mean
we're all on the same page
about something zooming out just a
little bit RIT's a local disagreements
notwithstanding from from we all believe
something very foundational that's why
we're here presumably and we didn't talk
about some very practical things like
what are the kind of things how can we
translate the concepts that we really
care about to not so much to the public
but into an educational context and make
make that take somehow we didn't talk
about sort of crack other than this sort
of communitarian or the mosques of
matter English though we didn't talk
about surf practical issues like that
which I care about and I think it would
have been really helpful for us so you
know just to Richard would so that's
something that I missed and I think
would be really valuable first for
subsequent discussions they've just you
know in education more generally what
role can our positions play in that
context so okay so I'm going to talk
very very briefly because um in in fact
I have so much material to go over in my
head just sort out that I them afraid of
saying too much but that in itself I
think is a measure of how for me how
successful this this conference was
about which I was extremely dubious um
I'm uh I think one thing that I really
want to think about and that I might
have changed my mind on is I think I'm
feeling that the manifest image in the
scientific image is closer then I used
to by way of neuroscience
I saw a they I actually feel that things
that I thought there was just no way of
bringing together and yesterday's
discussion about meaning was extremely
useful to me in in changing my my mind
about that that I actually think there
are some things we can say
about generating meaning intentionality
even mattering perhaps but it was just
it was - I'm now seeing them as somewhat
closer and I then I and I had before but
I have to think through that I'm this
thing about freewill my mind was not at
all changed I've been thinking a lot
about whether we should get rid of the
word yeah there for theoretical reason
yes I do think so it would clean things
up however it's very important never to
forget that there's a whole history of
discussion and that what we're saying is
a continuation of that discussion and it
it would be very very important and if
we do decide to change the word - not to
say we've dropped the ball you know that
we're we're answering certain questions
that have been discussed here or
presenting what to me is a very coherent
answer and so that you know that there's
a certain danger in I mean in changing
the vocabulary there because the the the
continuity of of the question what else
um I was a little disappointed in the
discussion of consciousness just because
I would have liked to hear more I would
have liked to hear more of a connection
between our discussion of the first day
in which we spoke about reduction and
explanation and entailment and what's
required for one level for you know to
be reduced another I would have I wanted
that brought home to consciousness and
what people here had to say about that
whether were there whether or not what
you know how far what you know I would
really would have learned if there was a
difference of opinion about that I would
have liked to have heard that another
connected with that another subject I
wish we had actually had on the board
was the self
that the nature of the self and Perry
you mentioned I think at the end of the
last discussion that none of this makes
sense without the notion of you know
sort of an organism acting undergoing
this and that was sort of a
parenthetically inserted there and I
think that's an extremely important
point and would have liked to have heard
that discussed the other thing was yeah
i've is very interested in the
discussion about our conscious reasons
better than unconscious reasons and dan
your remarks about you know it's
thinking's a kind of conversation and
there are different speakers that we
have going on there and once you make it
conscious you're making it available to
different Parsi i think that's for me a
very very useful idea and and it also
reminded me of the use of this kind of
thing you know this is because I mean
you know once you I mean we're putting
these things out there for not just
other parts of our minds to hear but
other people who are thinking about this
people from different disciplines
enormous lis enormous ly useful and so I
you know I would just I I wish that this
conversation could continue I wish that
we could not only push naturalism for
our word but uh this particular group I
would want to just keep talking to this
particular group about these issues
oh yeah first I wanted to thank Sean
again for organizing this and also Nick
for being the angel I'm giving me an
opportunity to meet some a intellectual
heroes a lot of people that I hope to
keep contact with I think for me the
most valuable part of the conference so
I think it's time I ever made contact
with a lot of people that I can have
discourse with in the future
particularly as I try to write this book
on naturalism and theology and I will
call you at some point I guess the
highlights for me of the meeting of
course the discussion of free will and
that's something that I thought I read a
lot about and I guess I'm gratified that
people seem to agree that it is a black
hole of with oh and that's a black hole
of philosophy I continue to disagree
with Dan if we tell people they don't
have free will that society will fall
apart I mean that arguments are made for
retaining religion and things like that
but but it hasn't happened in countries
like Fiona Naevia so I need to be
convinced by more than just performance
on whether you cheat and rather be free
well the discussion of entailment I
thought was enlightening to me
Stevens presentation of that how higher
levels can derive from lower levels I
remain unconvinced that there was any
qualitatively new phenomena that are not
entailed by the laws of physics but you
know I haven't seen anything I think a
period just seems impossible huh I
appreciated Mass and less discussion
particularly at the end on scientism and
ways of knowing you know it was a
remarkable clarity I thought and I would
have liked to discuss it long you're one
of the questions I have which was on
answering this meeting is are there
other ways of knowing besides saw not
through science is mathematics a form of
science are all questions about the
universe only resolvable through
empirical observation and I'm opening
that question yeah I hope to discuss it
maybe somewhere with Dan and I Drive
back to Boston the questions that are
unresolved to me
first of all I've
about what naturalism is that's shirring
still at this point what it is we've had
diverse definitions I don't think we
could move it forward until we know what
it is or at least we have a definition
that we all agree on but I think I made
the point that he doesn't think that
we've moved naturalism forward much here
and I think he's right but I don't think
this is the kind of venue to move
naturalism for I kind of the venue to
move nationalism for reason the
political realm because he dispel
superstition through improving the lots
of people in the world so that they
don't have to turn his superstition some
right I mean the best thing I can say to
do to move Nationals and forties to vote
for a bomb things I wish we had
discussed more are the concept of
morality and moral responsibility do
they have any meaning is what is there a
real meaning to being responsible versus
morally responsible and I hear diverse
opinions about that I'm not sure how I
feel about well actually I do I don't
think that people are morally
responsible I think they're responsible
in a technical sense but that's all the
other ways of knowing question I've
mentioned that's something I'm extremely
interested in I'll probably correspond
with some review about this is of course
used to enable theism religious people
say faith is another way of knowing and
we have all these other ways of knowing
they're efficacious like an art
literature music so why not through
revelation as well and I have to answer
this question in my book and I'm not
sure yet how to do it
I wish we had talked more about the
nature of reality what do we mean by
reality Stephen said everything is real
including God but only in the sense that
Santa Claus is real and I'm not quite
sure yeah I'm not sure you're any
remember except if an idea has a reality
which to me is different from where
because he does the reality before what
I've changed my mind about and to me
this is a substantial change is this
based on what Shawn and Dan and other
people said I wrote on my website this
morning that I did not think that the
formal discipline of the philosophy of
science had any contribution to make to
moving science forward' discussion this
morning I realize
now that that's not true and I am going
to correct myself
about that and I will correct myself on
that I hope with Dan based on his
kitchen free world also correct himself
by saying that now he agrees that free
will is equivalent to morally competent
volition so I'll make the deal with him
that all renege if he'll admit that
somewhere in France oh oh yeah that's
right said but people might want to edit
it out because politically expedient
okay
I think the you or I would still
disagree what we mean by that but anyway
that's the last point I wanted to make
and I thank everybody for talking to me
and Shawn and Nick for helping arrange
the whole thing okay I'm timing myself
so somebody mentioned maybe a couple of
people mentioned that we think veteran
groups and this is for me a perfect
example of that that as Rebecca said
sometimes philosophy is just so
intensely uncomfortable that it's easy
to opt to choose another path you know
moving forward in terms of the way I
think about the world but doing it in
this group setting has been incredibly
valuable for me where I really did feel
stuff shift and I think at the beginning
I said I would just love to have one
philosophical argument that falsified
some intuition that I had and I can't
say that I have that experience exactly
I think that some of my intuitions about
free will or some of the other things
like consciousness that we discussed are
intact but I also were exposed as being
outmoded and maybe part of the the
tradition or the mythology that needs
that we need to move beyond and so I'm
very happy to say that I think my ideas
now are have expanded and and that's
great and it's been such a privilege to
sit around a table with you especially
the dinner table on the lunch table but
I feel like a lot of the cultural
divides get broken down and then we come
back into the room a little
after each one of those encounters and I
think this is part of the idea that that
that what we're doing isn't just
intellectual and written on the page it
also has a community component a social
component I think we're feeling that
even in this room that as we start to
exchange and feel part of the same
community we progress better our
scholarship is improved we get into the
text better and so I feel like this was
an excellent start and I hope it is a
start I'm looking at Sean and Nick and
that this conversation will be continued
because now I think both conceptually
and culturally we're in a better place
to like take on hard core things that
like us so this wasn't hard core but you
know a new set of hard core things like
entropy and causality which has come up
a couple of times in the conversation
and and I would love to have a better
set of tools to use in thinking about
that when I'm approaching theoretical
physics and I'm thinking about about
time as I have to and I'm thinking about
the forward light cone or the past light
cone which I also should think of as the
causal future in the causal past right
and I need to do better in terms of
understanding those concepts and I would
love to be able to push on them with a
group like this and and with your help
and with you know as has come up
exposing to my own mind my own ideas
right through a different set of
receptors and and other than that I I
was sort of vaguely reminded of and
maybe this is complete nostalgia that's
inappropriate of a kind of Vienna circle
style thing happening here where you
know somebody was how you were talking
about metaphysics and and and you know
at the circle they sort of said let's
just toss away metaphysics entirely all
of these philosophical quandary are
simply an artifact of phrasing them
badly we all know that we believe in
math and physics let's just phrase them
properly and I think even dictionaries
of meaning versus semantics came up you
know we just have to have the right
meaningless discussions and and make a
dictionary later and add meaning onto
them and all of this stuff will be
cracked and there's power
that it's kind of you know the idea that
in all of mathematics we will prove
every mathematical fact now of course
some of that program failed but the way
it failed was in the most interesting
way it could possibly fail which is that
there's true facts among numbers that
simply can't be proven in the context of
arithmetic this is fantastic result and
I feel that you know our conversation is
sort of at that point we're like okay
we're natural ists let's phrase this
questions these questions better
properly nobody's going to accuse anyone
of dualism or or believing in fairies or
any of these metaphysical things and
instead we're going to progress but then
is there going to be something deeply
interesting down the road like physical
truths choose they're real there are
physical truths that simply can't be
gotten to in the way we would like to
imagine we can get to them and which is
to say I start with this set of axioms
as you do with arithmetic but in this
case maybe laws of physics and I plow
ahead as some things that struck me that
I hadn't appreciated before but again
probably intuitively felt could be a
startling change and shift in how we
think about it so I think all of you for
challenging you know me to dig a little
deeper and and oh how did I do in time
because oh man six seconds and I want to
now in the last half-hour allow for some
crosstalk because I thought that was
very leveling in terms of giving us an
all an opportunity to calibrate find out
where we all are and and and I'm sure
people have things to say to each other
bringing the formal discussions to a
close right here at this high note and
have that crosstalk conversation but
just do it completely more informally
where we can all let our hair down and
the room okay I just want to point out
I'm chair I know but I just have this
really great idea um I think we should
close the formal discussion and we're
should should we go down to like go down
to the Lions Den the video let's just
think ourselves
you